le rêve que mon ami blanc a tom
neumayr 6 que j'ai avec qui
brille par robby king dans un médium mais pas
il n'y a même pas de demi-champion par ahmed
mère basiouny qui n'est pas mara avec la moyenne
1 et et peut-être amélioration de la main avec le milieu
environnement ou marcher normalement pour aller à
kokid un homme et quelimane picorent omari 6
bar de la même façon je t'aime maman
la mère n'a pas de mouvement peut
affronter ou entraver toute mesure
antipopulaire de ce gouvernement alors nous
nous devons nous joindre
seules ces alliances à renforcer
des mouvements ensemble est que nous allons
arrêter ce programme tragique qui
représente le gouvernement le salaire
il était